well i hope everyone's happy we're here
we are
the swimsuit episode i i hope everyone's
proud of themselves
look i think you've faced this homework
of all of us
i'm this is sexually explicit i think
you it was your idea
it was well no she no no it was her idea
but she thought she was gonna somehow be
able to be the little in her director's
chair
no i think you know what it was it was
one of those ideas
when you're with a group of friends
you're like let's all go to bali
and it's like yeah like of course we're
gonna do that but when push comes to
shove
like nobody ever actually like buys a
ticket so it's like too expensive
somebody has a wedding that weekend like
i just never saw this day as we bought
the ticket we bought the tickets
we're in bali [ __ ] um let me say esther
i genuinely thought you were gonna show
up in
a rash car a rash guard i have one and i
almost did but then i was like no no not
a rash
a rash guard i was like i know i have to
negotiate
so if i cover up my my arms and like
legs would have to be exposed i was like
i'm gonna go for full maternity leggings
from the gap
and then it is good because it's up to
the tent
and then the sexually explicit i don't
understand bathing suits they're
they're sexually explicit yeah they're
horrible
that's because you guys just dip in the
pool like
i look for more function when i look at
swimsuits that's why none of mine are
actually sexy mine are like
like cool necks basically because i look
for whether or not they're going to stay
on my back
but you are going to die you're
stephanie seymour in this well stephanie
from baywatch
isn't her last name seymour no see
stephanie seymour is axel rose's
ex-girlfriend she's a super model
you're stephanie from baywatch yeah
[ __ ] i got concave tips i like it no no
your tits are
about 40 sizes bigger than hers well
we know the history of my tits don't we
pete but concave sounds painful
it sounds like like it hurts really she
did have painful tits though
i did have very rock hard huge painful
tits that i removed
let's just say she's it's been a real
roller coaster on that chest
and it's been up and down and uh no it's
down
and up and back down it's way back down
we're in the valley we are no longer in
the peak of the mountain
that's what upsets me the most about my
tits is that they
haven't necessarily gone down they've
gone sideways
and no one told me that when i took
implants out that that wasn't
a possibility i always thought okay i
was born that way so i don't want to
hear it i have wide set
titties they're pretty much under my
armpits that's why i have to wear this
is
a bra to me is a swimsuit top and i am
going to let you guys know i am
forfeiting
back fat to have the hoisting of the
small titties
explain that like okay so if if if this
band was looser then
this would be looser too and that it
wouldn't be as much of a hoist
so you're saying it's so tight that it's
giving you big titties
but it's also pushing up that's so tight
i'm i'm
i'm choosing the way you chose this
section
i'm choosing this section over like i'm
gonna let this
this flap out and i noticed your abs are
looking
really good yeah i've been working out
guys listen i knew this was coming up
i've stretched my penis a lot i've made
my penises as long as possible
that's what you guys do
[Music]
did we talk about this before about the
that some people use cinder blocks to
try to get their foreskin back
yes you did you bring this up i feel
like every week i
haven't gotten quite the reaction i'm
waiting for a message
i only know about docking but not about
stretching
um space docking what the
boat docking space is it's
um the shaft
of the head onto the inside of another
penis
yeah so andy and i can show you how it's
done later isn't it like uncircumcised
where you wrap things yeah you wrap it
over the
you're just offering a turtleneck to
keep but what does that do do you
remember earlier when you were like do
you have a sweatshirt i'm cold and
kaleila was like yes
it's like that it's like a penis sweater
if you're really cold
esther and we're in the arctic and i
said esther you're like
on my hands they're about to um what do
you get when you
they're about to be frostbitten and i
like esther the only place for you to
warm them up is
deep inside my [ __ ] i would say i
disagree that i'll go vagina
oh okay vagina's warmer than a butthole
i think
i feel like you have the right size of
introductory hands to go into an [ __ ]
though
you've got like starter butt plug size
hands
i've had bigger dicks than your hands
wait i want to ask you guys um what was
the prep
or what was the overall psychological
state leading up to this
i like that you're pretending you don't
know i i called everyone
there were texts there were there is a
paper we had a sad phone call
when i was hiding in the bathroom in my
hotel well what did it sound like
well at first she was like calming me
down and then 20 minutes later she
called me and she's like no i'm mad i
was [ __ ] pissed i was like all the
because i what i did was a codependent
move where i was like oh i'll just go
get your swimsuits for you
no you were like uh you were like it's
gonna be fine we just have to go into it
because we here's what's happening we
got this email that we're doing this big
only fan shoot
and and like it was gonna be fourth of
july themed and i'm like i don't have
any fourth of july stuff
i ca i can't believe you guys really
want me to be in a bikini for only fans
like i was freaking out and andy's like
no no it's gonna be fine
20 minutes later i'm not okay i was
[ __ ]
livid i was like are you guys [ __ ]
kidding me i'm on my period i'm the
fattest i've ever been
really that's the sound of my ass
dragging right now that's not even a
[ __ ] plane okay
it's a helicopter do you know a
helicopter i gotta i'm in my helicopter
phase right now okay i'm stout i'm round
but
it i just i it's set i was like and then
i was like
i'll go get your fourth of july stuff i
go to the [ __ ] thinking the venice
boardwalk boardwalk will be the place
that has like gimmicky things
nothing i was livid i was living look
guys um
we're not the type of girls that only
fans comes easy to
that that isn't necessarily our thing
which is why we're pushing ourselves to
be
it was really stressful today but i feel
like we got through it it was
fun everyone felt sexy i mean the shoot
was a little bit different than what i
thought it was
i mean why i forgot that i like am
a complete exhibitionist i don't know
that they'll ever make it to the only
fans to be real
but i mean i came in and it went from me
being like george
i never want to see you again in my life
you piece of [ __ ] to me walking and
being like should i pull my tampon
string in or out like should it be in
the picture
or out of the picture and he was just
walking around
like you looked like a man in a speedo
i'll put it that way
like a young one you are not wearing a
heavy man
no top no top but then so the reason i
brought this up is because
esther's little butt plug introduction
hands
there's a picture of them holding
cupping each one of my hands and one is
a regular hand
he's the hand of a child well i don't
have i have
lebron hands my hands are so big
and bobby's afraid of these he calls him
e.t fingers he's like you can never put
those
orifice go yeah look at how stretched
out you can go
you were struck yeah
that's what dave is like i've never seen
anything is that weird no no no no look
at her p sign it's her
this is her i don't understand dude it's
like your asian hips
sign if i'm trying to do it oh that's
because i'm double jointed
i could be in what do you call that um
cirque du soleil act
i thought you're gonna i was gonna say
rheumatoid arthritis i have that too
though
so i want to do a check-in of how
everyone's feeling about their bodies
right now because the point of this was
to
just be and let be right
just be who we are no matter what that
whatever shape we come in
yes but whatever pubes stick out because
guess what my pubes are sticking the
[ __ ] out
i that's why these pants are on i will
be real there were
for an asian person i was surprised at
the amount of pubes i saw
on me they were there were more pubes
than i thought that's from papa's side
of the family
and they were gray just like her you
know elderly father
i think i'm feeling better i like i said
i put this bikini top on this morning
and i i just i immediately texted a
picture of it
to my left lover because i was like i'm
gonna at least get what did dave say did
he see you
send the picture to your lover
was it a girl i i just feel
pornographic and you do if you wear like
a tight shirt it turns into a weird
thing it's weird i feel weird but i also
am kind of enjoying it i'm like you know
what
it's freedom people do this all the time
enough obviously like i'm kind of
cheating because i have them these
maternity pants on um but it's you know
once you start
her volume two of the swimsuit episodes
maybe i'll be in a little bikini
yeah i think we're gonna have several
iterations of bikini day
also another thing is this this isn't
just bikini day this is bikini and pizza
day
so later on i'll also have diarrhea
later i mean it's really excellent it's
uh to just really throw myself out there
just the chubbiest i've ever been in my
life
that was the negotiation because i said
let's do an episode where we taste test
all the like classic pizza places like
domino's little caesars you know
whatever it is
and and george was like no everyone does
that and i was like
[ __ ] and then annie goes what if we do
it in bikinis and jordan's like yeah and
then i was like
really [ __ ] so this whole thing was
really conjured up between you two
listen
uh there's gonna be a stephanie has a
problem with this there's gonna be a
moment
when i'm eating a slice of pepperoni
you're not sure if i actually am eating
a slice of pepperoni
what do you mean like it's gonna are
those her nipples or is it
oh you guys well i'm just glad i've been
doing my sit-ups i really have been
exercising a lot for this
and i can't i feel embarrassed now that
i'm freaked out because and it shows
i i mean mrs olympia i before the
shoot was scheduled i was at a six-pack
okay i actually have um
a question i want to bring up because
we've been talking about how we're doing
we're launching our only fans
and i saw this post on instagram by this
girl i follow alexi wasser
and i thought this was an interesting
topic and i read it out loud to dave
we just like we didn't know where to
land
and i want to know what you guys think
of it so it says
do all men follow a ton of cam or porn
girl instagram accounts
is this something that's just normal and
no big deal and shouldn't cause
upset or concern and instant reaction of
wanting to close one's heart and no
longer believe in love or fidelity
let me know if you just have to overlook
and accept a person's right to porn
and provocative insta accounts i think
some people watch porn and some people
don't like i
my friend um justin shanes who's a
writer
i love this guy but he posted in his
story
a screen grab of his discovery page and
he was like what
like this is so it was like all these
like weird animals and weird things
what the [ __ ] is this i was like then
just one picture of like reese
witherspoon and her
daughter but he was posting and i was
just the only thing i kept thinking is
like
how are there no pictures of asses and
stuff yeah
like i feel like most guys discovery
page is just like yeah
there was none of that where i was like
oh my god are you the only boy
i think we should look at our discovery
pages after this discussion but what i
want to say about that esther is um
i mean i have my own um like whether
it's
food whether it's gambling whether it's
sex whether
it's lettuce anything in excess
that gets in the way of friendships
relationships mental health
overall wellness let us talk about this
lettuce thing because i really have been
upset
every time i let us walk out with you
you are
eating lettuce and i'm like enough
enough enough
i haven't eaten lettuce in so long i
like arugula let's make it good thank
you [ __ ]
i think there's no clear answer because
i was looking at this and at first i was
like this is so
silly and then i was like well it's
actually really interesting like
so my so dave my partner like
we're both very open you know well this
is for example like i looked at his tick
tock
like we were like looking at each
other's tick tock and one time when i
looked at it
his algorithm was like all like cute
young woman with huge boobs like
bouncing around
honestly this is not normal but not
threatening either because it's your
at least his type i had a friend whose
boyfriend
she caught looking at all this like
titty [ __ ] porn and she's like
flat and it was like that's a problem
but i don't care like i almost
i i welcome that like i think it's
actually cool i think it basically if
you love and trust that person
it kind of doesn't really matter what
they're well that's a good point the
discussion
isn't about whether it's allowed as a
whole what's unhealthy what's not
healthy
a lot has to do with your relationship
with your partner because i mean for me
there was a point in our relationship
where i was like
i think that porn is getting in the way
of your dick properly functioning
like bobby says it himself like he had
erectile he had
porn erectile dysfunction because he was
watching a bunch of this stuff on hd
and he sort of like you know it really
was a hit
on my um what do you call it on my
self-esteem
not because i didn't want him watching
porn or that i even
stacked myself against those women well
because
he was jerking off more to that than
actually being with me physically so i
was like wait like you cannot
that's a problem you should try not
talking so much you know what the point
is you think me
talk just mirror you are you projecting
well she talks too i talk i talk annie
she talks too as well as well but yeah
that's such a that's too
broad it's really hard annie would you
would it bother you
if if todd is like following hot girls
or like
if it doesn't like come into my life i
don't care i would just rather not know
i don't care like i don't it doesn't
bother me
but i could see if i was really in a if
i was feeling insecure in my
relationship
if i felt like i wasn't pretty enough
wasn't skinny enough all the things
and i was dating some guy and i saw who
was looking at like really hot girls
that would drive me crazy i would feel i
would feel like [ __ ] i wouldn't would it
okay
wouldn't that be your issue and that you
would have to work on because
no because if you not if you at your
most confident doesn't care
then that's but does care when you're
don't you just have to work on your
confidence
no i disagree i think it's the
relationship as having a problem it's
not me
it's you're not making me feel right
yeah totally yeah
yeah but that's how i mean kind of like
if it if it spills over into my life
like if all of a sudden your dick's not
working when it's for me
yeah or like you're
yeah you're paying more attention to it
or whatever then that's an issue but if
it doesn't come into my life do whatever
the [ __ ] you want
i remember when um i had just
gotten a heart ablation and i was
feeling just really icky about
you know i was always in pajama anyways
um that's when
a lot of bobby's like porn um addiction
started happening
so combined with my already eric griffin
was right
about you got to wear a little more
lingerie
what i'm saying is that while i was sick
compounded with someone you know seeking
something else and not trying to engage
with me because he thinks like i was a
sick person at that time
really [ __ ] with me but now if i look
at his explore page it's very similar
where it's like yeah it's a lot of
chicks but it's not it has zero
natural effects on me now yeah but
there's also a lot of
work on my own [ __ ] too it sucks when
you
like a couple bad things at once like i
remember
i had just gotten dumped and then i had
in high school
and i had to wear a boot on my ankle and
i
normally don't pay your parking ticket
normally i would be so proud of wearing
a boot like i wouldn't care it would
just i think it was funny
i would feel different you didn't have
anyone to push you around you had to
just
deal with it no but it was like i was so
insecure after being dumped
that the boot was like the end of the
world i'm so surprised because i thought
you would have been one of those kids
that was like
i love this boot attention but that's
what i'm saying is that's what i would
have been if i hadn't
just gotten dumped it was like i
remember i always remember i can see you
being one of those people where we find
out there's no
foot problem you just gotta boot from
like a secondhand store a hundred
percent yes
you're right you would you would did you
let people sign your boot or your cast
no no no no because it was actually
that's why he broke up with you
he's like let's see other people
no i was it was detachable it wasn't
something that people signed was it the
royal one
yeah that's really interesting esther i
think that it's it's
a very personal thing between two people
how they feel about their partners
because it would be a different
relationship too like it's like it just
depends on who the person is how much
you trust them
so many of my friends do sex work we're
right here
i know we're on only fans now we're sex
workers oh my god
and i'm just saying it's like but like
if you look at this [ __ ] only fans
and you come to my show
thinking you're ever gonna [ __ ] me i
swear to god
everything gets taken we stopped doing
the podcast it's done do you understand
guys yeah don't [ __ ] this stop talking
to me
man sir
annie it's summer it's camping season
let's talk about pitching tents
this that's right yeah boners what kind
of tent
oh wait you you beat me to it uh
that's right we're talking about blue
chew
it is time to
bone up guys okay and ladies get this
for your man too
because blue chew is a unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as viagra and
cialis but in chewable tablets at the
fraction of the cost
you can take them anytime day or night
so you can plan ahead or be ready
whenever an opportunity arises
and the process is so simple you sign up
at bluechew.com consult with one of
their licensed medical providers
and once you're approved approved you'll
receive your prescription within days
the best part it's all done online so no
visits to the doctor's office no awkward
conversations and no
waiting in line at the pharmacy blue
chews tablets are made in the u.s
of a and prepared and shipped direct to
your door in a discreet package
guys there's nothing sexier than
confidence can we agree
and blue chew can help give you
confidence when it counts so if you
could benefit from
extra confidence in the bedroom when
it's time to perform
bluetooth can help and we've got a
special deal for our listeners
try blue chew free when you use our
promo code bathgirls at checkout
just pay five dollars shipping that's
bluechu.com promo code bathgirls
to receive your first month free visit
bluechew.com
for more details and important safety
information
ladies blue chew is exclusively for men
but the end result is something you'll
both enjoy
so thank you for sponsoring this episode
you know what everyone on this show
loves um is it
magic spoon it is
no but it really is i love magic why did
we ever have to stop eating cereal
because it was so bad for you so sugary
we couldn't deal with esther's
sugar swings up all night cue magic
spoon with zero grams of sugar
13 to 14 grams of protein and only four
net grams of carbs in each serving and
only 140 calories per serving but all
the flavor
oh the flavor yes and we have been
hearing from you guys that you really
like it and you have been enjoying it so
you can choose from cocoa fruity frosted
peanut butter blueberry
and cinnamon and their keto friendly
gluten-free grain-free soy-free low-carb
and gmo free you have to get fruity you
can mix them i haven't tried this but i
would like to do like
maybe the peanut butter and the
blueberry oh
fancy that would be like peanut butter
and jelly well i put it in my
smoothies so why not that's so smart or
you can also do cocoa
and peanut butter and you can have
peanut butter cup magic spoon we
genuinely love magic spoons so much
go to magicspoon.com bathgirls to grab a
custom bundle of cereal and try it today
and be sure to use our promo code
bathgirls at checkout to save five
dollars off your order
and magic spoon is so confident in their
product it's backed with a 100
happiness guarantee so if you don't like
it for any reason they'll refund you no
questions asked
and remember get your next delicious
bowl of guilt-free cereal at
magicspoon.com
bathgirls and use the code bathgirls to
save five dollars off
thank you magic spoon for sponsoring
this episode we love you
i'm gonna tell you guys about how this
is why i have to stop smoking weed okay
i have a i have i quit smoking weed
every day
every single day what time do you
relapse i wake up in the morning
the brain you quit it every day every
day
every day i wake up in the morning and i
go i quit i go
wow i must been i remember quitting weed
last night i was so high i must have
quit weed
and then later that day i smoke weed
again like isn't that crazy
i quit smoking weed and then i'm so high
again i'm like i gotta quit this this is
horrible why do you
want to quit it and then what makes you
keep doing it it's a bad thing to do at
the end of the day
i've had this whole day what makes it
bad it's just like
i'm being like a bat but i i have said
this before like i actually think
smoking weed is not bad it's not cool
like it's not like bad in the cool way
like cigarettes are anymore because it's
legal so it's like you have to do it i
would say like if you want to be
qualified to
do it out of your tracheotomy hole but
that's a stage bit so if you come see me
listen if you come see me and i do that
joke [ __ ] you okay
you're not allowed to be mad at me fake
laugh but okay what about smoking weed
leads does it lead you to
other activities that you don't wanna
yes like last night day before the
full panic attack about the swimsuit
thing like literally everyone has like
it's all blue like there's like 10 blues
in a row on everyone's text chain
okay like one word answers where
everyone's like chill yesterday was
uh national donut day or maybe they just
love it you know that
todd because todd wanted donuts it was
on instagram where did you guys go
why do i know that how is that a weird
thing to know
[ __ ] your dog's name is donut you don't
know where donuts are
excuse me the person that would know the
most oh my god you missed donut's
birthday
it's not her birthday it's not a real
day everyone knows that it's not a real
it's
to know on instagram guys went to go
todd wakes up he's like
todd wakes up he's like i want donuts
i'm not having donuts at this point i'm
like i'll go with you
i'll bring randy i'm not going to have
you he'll burn yeah
i heard that i will
burn this [ __ ] dog if you bring that
donut near me i will i have like a
lighter up to his eyes
randy you better not fart i am in a
[ __ ] bird no but um
no bring randy so randy's in my lap we
go to the donut shop wait where did you
go
well todd loves dunkin donuts so he
finds you you live too
you're a really good donut place so
todd's excited about dunkin donuts we go
i don't give a [ __ ] i'm not getting
donuts
so we go there is so much traffic that
we end up
todd's having road rage i was on the
phone with someone while todd was having
full road rage um then there was nowhere
to park and he's like [ __ ] it we're not
getting donuts so
we leave and then um someone could run
in
is there no it was like annoying it was
no i didn't nobody wan
it was a forced situation and todd very
rarely gets upset
but he was upset yesterday so we leave
and then later in the day my friend and
i go to when
a place called wendy's donut shop but it
was so good you are seeing a place
called
wendy's yeah
no but there's a wendy's donut shop we
found okay and we were going to the
tanning salon
and uh i don't know if you guys noticed
my sweet spray tan
um so it's a very early 2000s story i
feel
like spray yeah so i
we get todd because like i didn't want
my angel to be upset i'm codependent i
got him like a thousand donuts okay
a thousand donuts and they were all like
that didn't fill they didn't fit into
the like we were gonna get a half dozen
and then they were like that's an extra
dollar that's i got them all like the
gourmet ones
bring it back todd does not overeat so
todd had one bite of a donut
and then all these donuts were hanging
out but i was fine i was like i'm not i
have my bikini thing tomorrow
i'm not gonna eat these i go to the
comedy store
i i literally i'm in the middle of a
conversation with mark maron going
mark i'm on weed again i'm gonna have to
go to aaa meetings for weed
jeff ross's friend comes up and goes do
you want this joint and i was like oh
that's fate sorry mark and i like grab
the joint
and then i'm high as [ __ ] and then i go
home and i eat
every donut that's left shoving it in
and i was like i just can't wait to chat
at least it'll be funny on the podcast
it'll be funny on the podcast
woke up just like donut diarrhea in the
morning i don't know if you guys have
ever read
but everyone what a gift i know you just
get rid of it right away oh
that's a good point my [ __ ] does my [ __ ]
sticks
same three days before that toilet sees
those donuts oh i wake up in the morning
i
so i will eat well i have a great day
and
not in an eating disord disordery way
not in a way where i'm like trying to
not just i just have a productive good
day thank you for calling it out though
because what esther and i did was a very
eating disordery way
yeah we like we praise diarrhea oh
it's a gift from god but it does feel
good after wait
what what an eating disorder your way
though it does feel better to get rid of
what
can i know some of the premium flavors
of donuts
okay one was like an apple fritter
fritter obviously
um there was a cinnamon roll one cream
filled
but it was like whipped cream filled it
was i ate that whole one that was so
good it was a triangle was this big and
then i had chocolate frosting on the top
were they really good was the place go
[ __ ] amazing every bite was winter
shout out and then um it has a capital
d when and then it's can we do a donut
taste test episode
yeah we'll do it today i have i have a
question
um so i while i like donuts i grew up
loving munchkins a doughnut i love you
is there a doughnut hole
um a national doughnut hole day like do
we know i think it falls under donuts it
cannot because
no it's today it is guys the day this
comes out
is hashtag national
[Music]
national donut whole day so start it
post your pics we'll reboot well that
sounds sexual now
where are the only fans [ __ ] you're the
only fans girl what are your favorite
donut places in aleyster
um there's a place called blue star and
there's something else so fancy first
place
the coffee place too there's something
else like i feel like venice has
a blue star and has something else
that's really good that i'm not
remembering the name oh
there's i've always wanted to try
sidecar donuts in santa monica but i've
never tried
a donut friend yeah i like doing a fried
doughnut friend is all vegan
yes um come on but it is really good
though annie really lately so annoying
lately i've been thinking a lot about
old school just like a fresh [ __ ]
california donuts i've never had that i
want like a cream yeah a fresh hot
krispy kreme
you are [ __ ] you i could see you just
downing it does
but i don't usually go for donuts
because they're so filling that you can
really only eat one
oh i haven't always already had several
bagels by that point yeah
i like a chocolate chip cookie where i
know i can like i got three or four
and i can feel okay guys again if you
ever have esters baking it is like
they're not sweet
it's literally like you're not eating a
doughnut those cookies you had i really
liked them
you did yeah well how bad were the ones
before then
the best part was too that it was social
distance then like we were right
now on the other side so you couldn't
see my face just recoiling after
i could tell you weren't eating them and
you wouldn't be honest with me until
later
i think that we should have an episode
where you serve us your cookies and i
will give you a very unbiased
oh she's going to try harder i don't
want her trying harder and he still gets
the bad ones
the unsweetened ones i get the sweet
ones what are your favorite
flavored donuts i like a cronut i had a
uh
that's not a flavored doughnut a glazed
grown up for him too is one of the other
oh
you know what but okay you know what
it's like my if like speaking of eating
to sort of talk like what would be like
an unsafe food where like i would go too
crazy cinnamon roll
if you get me near a cinnamon roll i
will like i'd kill everyone in this
backyard
do you bite straight or do you unroll um
i eat it with a knife and a fork
and i just kind of go in but do you do
it with the
the i'll eat a little bit of the outside
i'll go a little inside i go back and
forth so there's a method it's a
nightmare
and i dip in there and my mom should
just go on a mall date together because
that's her favorite
mom she'll steal them off people's
plates the smell
the the icing like oh um
i gotta i have to leave what if she got
so excited she fell in the pool
how happy would you guys be i'm esther
there is this sport that i think is made
for you and
if it became an olympic sport i think
you should try out okay so there's a
competition
in korea it's called the spacing out i
think it's called
i don't know what they call it but you
basically sit on the forest and the
winner
is the person who does the least
is so zoned out of their minds and they
measure like the heart rate they measure
the blood pressure
and you do nothing you just sit there i
can tell you why she can't do that
because it's not that esther doesn't
like things being done
she just has that you would need someone
to be doing stuff for you you would be
thinking about other things
because i just saw you take a nap right
now like esther could win this well that
wasn't and
here's the thing to even brag more that
wasn't a nap
i was just like completely shut down in
rest mode
like almost like i told you some really
important stuff that'd be funny if i was
like coming clean
that's what shut me down i i
need to talk i just i you power off you
like re-energize it's almost like a
version of meditating even though that
word like
is triggering because i don't know how
to meditate but um i and i do have
really low
blood pressure so i do think you're not
wrong i have an idea
what can we make a shirt that says the
word meditating is triggering
[Laughter]
i'm not allowing that line to just go
that must be
made money off of i can't meditate can
you
there's nobody triggered by the word i
meditate
a hundred percent i meditate i meditate
every day every day
meditate i meditate and i also do a
visualization
what do you think about oh i'm sh being
showered by
gold coins i'm diving coins
she wants coins yeah i want to feel a
little pain i want to earn the
i'm bruised up i'm bleeding my teeth are
flying out
wait i can't ask you guys is there is
there
um back in the day you know when the
dollar wasn't
what it is now like competing when your
dad was young
1924 back in 1910. could you
could you go to a strip club and bring a
bag of coins and would that fly
yeah you make it hail boom oh that was
interesting
like because a quarter was must have
been so much money back then but were
there even strip clubs in the 20s
now i'm about to say something that i
just wanted you guys to know it's
fake i don't really want to do this it's
just a thing i'm gonna say
let's do a stripper themed episode okay
but let's never do that
okay let's actually never do it but i'm
just saying why are we not
the meltdown that would ensue from all
of us the day before
no well let's do the stripper one but we
have to i want to actually have a
teacher or something teach
us well i don't really want to actually
you're going to be good on a [ __ ]
no we're not going to take our clothes
off look at what i i've triggered
i triggered you i got excited i got
we're going to do an activity
no i did go to one of those pool dancing
class once in chicago and i
it's like impossible it's not so hard
nicole byers good at it
girls who just throw themselves up there
and can do the things i don't i bet
kaleila could do it but it seems so
probably strong enough it's just that my
hands sweat you guys and my feet sweats
but it's not your hands are not the
things holding you at all i mean they're
still going to be applying
don't some women have gloves or like
powder yeah powder
oh my god like rock climbing i use that
every day of my life you guys to like
hold a pen i like
her wait did you see the way she went
like this i had a powder
i used to do that i used to bring powder
like even during like my nursing
rotations
i used to have a little bag of powder
here because i couldn't put gloves on
you got arrested for that that was the
best thing in the world
i thought you had coke well someone
someone would love your hands were
mildly sweaty it was like oh yeah honey
all you need to do is just put some
powder before you put the gloves on
and i made cake batter with my hands
that's what the [ __ ] happened like it
did not work at all that's why i quit
nursing i was like [ __ ] this can't do
this my hands
will not agree okay two things there's
two memories were just triggered
um one was one i forgot but one was
i when i was a waitress
i'll remember it though put a pin in
whatever you just said before this that
i also forgot
this is the weed and the 80d i can't i'm
giving myself early onset alzheimer's by
smoking weed don't joke about that dude
when i looked at my 23andme it don't
make it not a joke
by saying that dude ew
now you're gonna get it too cause you
said it that'd be so funny if we were
all
in a nursing home what if we are now
what if we've died
what if we're on our death beds right
now and this is us reliving our lives
you
stop that if you were wise though if you
were a golden girl who would you be
i didn't watch the show i don't know
which one against the [ __ ] one the [ __ ]
one what is your actual problem
who oh um what's your name blanche yes
yeah blanche i always think of eliza's
dog when i heard the name blanche
oh that's so cute so anyway so i when i
was working as a waitress
my thighs chafe like i am going to miami
on a vacation in puerto rico and i am
so scared of just the situation with my
bleeding inner thighs can i
just say something my thighs chafed too
but you know what they don't
because i never put them in a position
to chafe no but it doesn't even matter
because think about being in but in a
in a wet hot climate it's i can't wear
like sweatpants and [ __ ] but you can
wear
bikes you don't have the same listen
it's not the same thing when i was
waitressing so i would wear
like leggings underneath my skirt and
everything i'd have to wear all black
and it's still [ __ ] shaped it still
did it what do you mean
can you explain that it's just rubs it's
like you know how like when you have
pants like
do your pants get pilly in between i i
don't wear anything but sweatpants
what do they get and they don't move
enough to get pills you don't see that's
the thing you have chafing but you're
also
sitting you're on a chase lounge that's
what she thinks chafing is
um i thought there would be a bigger
laugh but that's all right
can't water you can't win them all you
just keep going
yeah just keep going sometimes i do that
on stage when i'm just in the middle i
just
complete internal monologue uh justin
martindale went before me last night and
in the middle of my set as he walked by
went oh there's justin like
why did he stay in the middle of my set
everyone's like
justin which one timberlake go get them
okay
so i'm waitressing and i'm chafing
through my leggings i'm like
it's just so bad it hurts so bad i have
to walk around
so someone had told me that if you get
um
not baking powder what's the other one
uh baking soda
will help you can put that in between
and it'll help the chafing
like so on your cornstarch cornstarch
oh i gotta get out that so i go
into the kitchen that's bad what i have
a sensory issue with corn starch what i
understand
because it drives me it's almost like
it's worse than chalk on
um nails on chocolate okay so we'll use
a different word
don't say it because like powder will
just say i go into the kitchen and ask
for the powder
the special powder honestly cornstarch
is just making me think i want to make
an apple pie tonight
not a rhubarb no i don't have any
rhubarb
what is rhubarb we've talked about this
is a beautiful
every week what a terrible podcast
every week we get to the bottom of
rhubarb this is the worst podcast ever
wow they keep repeating their rhubarb
story wow so you put cornstarch in
between your
my coop my my parts
no the lips the lips are also okay but
that's just
anyway that's a different situation what
kind of pie did you make
the lips are not in the story okay get
the lips out of the story perverts
all right so my my chafing inner thighs
my
opposite of a thigh gap my thigh
filling oh let's just say i need to use
our ass tape sponsor to pull my thighs
out
so i'm wearing i'm i going to get the
cornstarch from the kitchen and i have
to convince them these are not my pals
these mexicans hate me okay
they do not like me at this restaurant
so i'm like i finally talked them into
the cornstarch i figured out a way to
get it i don't remember how he did it
but they gave me a little cup of it
and i knew it was gold i knew i was
never gonna get it again so i was like i
gotta stash it somewhere and in new york
and all of the bathrooms
they have these um postcard holders
that are just these cases that have like
different people advertise different
postcards
so i put it in this little cup
this little side serving cup of powder
in the thing and um like three days
later the manager
this guy mitch comes out and he's like
what the [ __ ] is this
who's this is he screaming thinking it's
like coke or drugs or something
and the kitchen guys are like it's like
shut the [ __ ] up like it's anita i'm
like it's not me it's not anita
and and they're like i don't know and
finally i had to be like all right my
[ __ ]
thighs chafe okay everybody my thighs
are bleeding
and everyone's like oh okay you can have
the cornstarch i'm just like all right
but it was so
i would have just got a flour instead of
corn starch because it at least like
it absorbed the moisture yeah the better
cornstarch i think it like makes things
gelatinous yeah
well diet was already making some
gelatinous stuff there okay i was
already
what it was already a little jello in
there
fun fact most home remedies and
over-the-counter acne products don't
work and even worse they can actually
damage your skin
but do you know what actually does work
prescription treatments that's why we're
so excited to partner with apostrophe
the sponsor of this episode apostrophe
is a prescription skincare company that
offers science-backed oral and topical
medications that are clinically proven
to
help clear acne listen you don't have to
wear it put toothpaste on your face
before you go to bed anymore
okay apostrophe connects you with a
board-certified dermatologist who will
create a personalized treatment plan
that is perfectly tailored to your
unique skin simply fill out apostrophe's
online quiz about your skin goals and
medical history
then snap a few selfies and your
dermatologist will create your
customized treatment plan how cute is
that
now i always like to like my one of my
problem areas is dark spots and sun
damage
i have eczema um and i also have melasma
on my upper lip that makes it look like
i have an actual mustache even though
there isn't hair there and i have an
actual mustache
so to have a dermatologist on like a
virtual dermatologist has been a
freaking dream because everyone should
have access to
yeah and they make it easy and also the
unboxing experience is super cute they
come with stickers you can personalize
your prescription bottle
and you the best part is you don't have
to go to the fricking pharmacy
you guys we have a special deal for our
audience save 15 off your first visit
with a board
certified dermatologist at
apostrophe.com bathgirls when you use
our code
bathgirls and this code is only
available to our listeners to get
started
just go to apostrophe.com bathgirls and
click begin visit then use our code
bathgirls
at sign up and you'll get 15 off your
dermatology visit
that's a-p-o-s-t-r-o-p-h-e
dot com slash bathgirls and use the code
bath girls to get your dermatology visit
and save fifteen dollars
and we thank you apostrophe for
sponsoring this podcast
you guys i am obsessed with stitch fix
shopping for new clothes can be
needlessly stressful
so why not let stitch fix make it easy
by doing the work for you so you can
spend time doing the things you love
instead look for me the pandemic really
shut down
my overall appearance and my want to
my want for style but now that i'm back
into the world i want to reintroduce
myself to society stitch fix
stitch fix has been a lifesaver i love
it
i i want to go to the store anymore no i
can't stand being in line for longer
than two minutes and then you have to
try everything on you can't find the
right thing it makes you feel so special
too because
stitch fix offers clothing hand selected
by expert stylists
for your unique size style and budget
it's a completely different and fun way
to find clothes that you will actually
love to wear
every piece is chosen for your fit and
your life and it's the easy solution to
finding what makes you
look and feel your best and if you try
on the pieces at home before you buy it
it's not like you have the right
lighting you have the right yeah
it's not like a cheat mirror yeah it's
like you try them on
before you buy them you keep what you
love and you return what you don't
stitch fix has free shipping easy
returns and exchanges and a prepaid
return envelope is included
there's no subscription required so you
can try stitch fix
once you set up automatic deliveries
you'll pay just 20 styling fee for each
box
which gets credited towards pieces you
keep and there's no hidden fees ever
you guys get started today at
stitchfix.com
bathgirls and you'll get 25 off when you
keep everything in your fix
that's stitchfix.com bathgirls for 25
off when you keep everything in your fix
go to stitchfix.com
bathgirls
have you guys seen the movie back in the
day
oh my god i want you to fall back you
know what i'm gonna say i would take you
with me [ __ ] i would grab one of those
pigtails i'd be like thank god it was
pig tail day
i would swing you around how propeller
are you
have you guys seen the movie powder no
george was in it what are you talking
about george show a leg just pop one of
your big ass calves in front of you and
show how white you are
ask her have you seen i know annie has
seen it because she has a reaction to it
it was a 1995 movie i can't believe your
parents didn't take you to watch this
traumatized
like has a rejection of anything that
would would help us in conversation
it's like her little body knew back then
don't watch this movie what is it
so it's um so it's a movie about um
gosh like now it would never fly because
number one the main character
he's he's um he suffers from he's yeah
he has albinism
and but on top of that he does albinism
it's organism
i know but how do you know all these
words
albinism though we know about albino
folks people without
i never her like i know what it means
when she says it
i know what it means she says it too but
it's it doesn't sound like a town in new
york
i'll say this it doesn't upset me when
she says that thank you it doesn't make
me feel
small i know dumb dumb because you
[ __ ] would never have known the word
she's like i knew and you couldn't lie
to me you were gonna try well here's
another word you're not gonna like so he
couldn't grow hair either so he had
alopecia i know that one
okay good um but his mom when she was
pregnant was struck with
struck by lightning right and now he has
like electromagnetic
um fields going through his body so when
he like rages out
it like shuts the lights off like he has
like the super power right
and i want you guys i want to know if
you think a movie like that would fly
today
why what is inappropriate about it he's
albino it's suggesting that people who
are albino
well it was a guy with who didn't it's a
white guy it's the guy from
sean patrick flannery yeah who they just
took a white guy and made him painted
him whiter yeah
when there's like victor varnado as a
friend of mine who's albino he could
have done it like there's like albino
actors that are like dying
they're like pitching they're probably
in hollywood right now pitching powder
too like
now that finally we'll get our
representation oh
is that what your question is yeah
because they had didn't they shave his
head
grow hair and i have a friend i um one
of my good friends shayna she has
alopecia
i have friends too though and um so i
that that would definitely not fly
today right albino actor yeah you would
have to have another like
there's no way i grew up with a guy
named i think his name was hairullah
haitula
what he was from the south of the
philippines but
he was from hyrule or hyrule
is low and i that was his uh
first name and surname but i saw hyrule
high too i think was his name
shout that's out my last name it is you
didn't know that her last name
but he was such a fast swimmer and he
just killed it in all the races but
he had extra digits on each so he had
six
six six twelve and then one on each
and they disqualified him oh my god i
would love to see the casting of well he
could never swam
internationally even because i swam for
the philippine team right he was not
allowed
on the national team because they said
it was yeah it was extra digit
do you know you're a big swimmer do you
really think that would that cause a
huge advantage
no because one of them was hanging like
if anything that was a drag
not a yeah but um because the other ones
were
pretty um how did i say like they were
like real digits and not hanging they
said that he wasn't
i felt so bad for this kid he was like
so talented
so fast and also like do you know how
hard it is like
to just be a fast swimmer regardless of
how many [ __ ] digits like you could
give some people
10 10 fingers on each one hand and they
still couldn't swallow who decides who's
disqualified though it's like the
the main olympic olympic people yeah
like i remember when i was 12 they made
me do like a gender test
like when i had this
what is the gender test again to prove
if i was like biologically or hormonally
female
12 years old esther and i was in
indonesia how do you take the test
and i don't remember what it was but i
had to carry maybe
i had to carry a card on my chest and
one of when
when you have our athletes like cards
and stuff it says like gender
and whether or not it's been proven it's
it was insane and i was 12 like
okay we can only imagine how small the
tits were then i mean
i mean annie they were muscles they
weren't tits i
when i was on the swim team and my
armpit hair grew in and nobody told me i
was like that is one of the things i'm
still mad at my mom for i'm like mom
just why didn't you tell them to shimmer
pits
oh you were allowed to shave your
armpits at that age i wasn't alive oh no
i was allowed my mom just was like it
didn't occur to me to
that you were disgusting everyone around
you i want to ask you did your parents
just always allow you to wear makeup
or like dress a certain way yeah i just
i remember i like
i don't know how i decided i wanted
makeup but one day i was like i think i
would look really pretty with like a
black line under my eyes that was like
two days ago
and i took a picture of myself and i
drew with marker the makeup on my face
like in the picture and i was like oh i
have to do this and then i but i was it
was like
i think i would i would consider
appropriate age like 12 or 13.
i was 12 or 13 yeah were you allowed to
wear a bra or wear deodorant
or shave your legs yeah i didn't really
have a lot of rules what a mean thing to
do to yourself to not let your kid wear
deodorant well that's what happened to
me
i wasn't allowed to wear bra i had good
reason
no tits were sprouting but um yeah i
wasn't allowed to wear a bra i wasn't
allowed to wear
um or to pluck out hair or do any of
that
like they there is a part i don't know
your eyebrows are good because of that
oh let me tell you the chola days took
over
i know we're all very blessed that our
eyebrows grew back i don't know if you
went
i never my parents wanted to infantilize
me as long as i
could like i remember like when i was
like 10 i was still running around
in on only underwear at home and like my
cousin's like a
drum instructor came over and by this by
this time i was like five four
you know what i mean a five foot four
ten-year-old just running around
with my hair out and then i would walk
around like go to like the fruit stand
in the corner
with no clothes on what i have there's
pictures of me
at 10 like in just like underwear
there's like one picture of me with like
a bat
like just completely topless you guys i
think it's time
for it for the big moment we didn't even
have a banana break
well our banana break today is the pizza
trial
[Music]
okay this is why pizza hut this is
cheese i'm gonna be partial to pizza hut
i already know it
it's my childhood okay so first we're
tasting pizza hut and i think we got
from each place
um it looks like this is original pan
style oh my god you're so excited about
this it's so annoying
i hate this i just want to be i want to
come out and say i hate this segment
and it's not because of the segment it's
the joy it brings the munch
so this is pizza hut i have all cheese
they have hawaiian
oh my god it's so good are you disgusted
by hawaiian no
i used to get pepperoni and um pineapple
but i don't like ham on really
i'm gonna go ahead and say that they've
definitely um
slimmed their dough down since childhood
because that was one of my favorite
things is that the layer of cheese was
thicker when i was younger um and
but i will say the taste is comparable
and i'm not
i would give it a c plus in terms of
hawaiian
i i need to rank them against each other
but this one so far
it doesn't have a lot of sauce yeah i
feel like i'm having a hard time tasting
the sauce
yeah it doesn't taste that good it's
very boring but
the first bite i'm like oh it's yummy so
i want to say the presentation
is cute it's cute
it's too perfect should we do like a
real like a so i'm gonna give this pizza
okay i think
the first bite tasted really good i
would want to keep eating it but i'm not
tasting sauce
i like that the crust is not too thick
not too thin
i would give this like a c this [ __ ]
sucks honestly
it's cold george that's right um
it's just not flavorful it's not
it's like i guess i like how all the
things are but i don't even taste
i like the bite of when you bite oh my
god there's a kitty just shut up george
give us dominoes
give your credit give me the dominoes
[Music]
wait i just want to know before we start
on a domino's
are you already partial do you already
know which one you're going i literally
have no idea i've heard though that
domino's has up their game over the
years and it's really good
but i also see papa john's over there
which is like my favorite
well this papa john the person um um
does it get in the way of your decision
making no no no one will no i cannot be
bought
i cannot be n worded out of either i'm
gonna go ahead and say
okay dominoes looks really good i'm very
excited with the presentation
presentation looks way better because i
do like irregularities i don't like how
neat and clean that last
pizza was i like the bubbles
yeah it looks good i'm a crust person
yeah this looks a little bit burnt crust
is always very good this is better soft
too that's a little too soft
i'm still having problems tasting sauce
okay but this is better
now that i've eaten this that little
pizza is such trash
that i wouldn't even let them sponsor
this podcast unless they really wanted
to
again while i am not an avid meat eater
i prefer
the smaller bits of meat on the pizza
hut
but overall this is a b-plus in my book
there's something tastier about this one
i taste the sauce more in this one too
you couldn't taste a [ __ ] thing in
that other one
and the crust has like it almost looks
like it has little garlic
like flakes or something like the crust
someone has paid attention to this crust
this crust has not been neglected
i give it a b flat i
give it a b plus i feel like your abs
are coming out more
so yeah i also feel like it's hard to
tell unless you try them you have to try
them all
which have them all in your mouth at the
same time oh my god
what what happened to this place it
looks like it has
it looks it looks good i swear guys this
looks not good to me but i'm very
excited about the special garlic sauce
i i just this is not how i remember papa
john's there's an ant crawling on it
which i'm okay with i don't know
we love ants it's a black and white oh
it's really hard yeah we're bringing
back
black living things it's very hard
garlic sauce is coming out oh wait rbc
that's a cheat
the garlic sauce no but it doesn't
matter because they offer it and they
bring it in everyone their
their [ __ ] pizza box has a little
place for it it shouldn't be a cheat
you're right right it's like that other
places could bring us garlic sauce we're
not stopping them
by the way um tomato sauce is gonna make
me choro
oh yeah diarrhea oh i'm gonna be on the
toilet okay this one is
very tasty but it doesn't it's not as
good as domino's because you need the
garlic sauce
too much sauce i just drank the garlic
sauce what
i didn't mean to try to open it with my
tea here let me help you baby oh my god
the garlic sauce
is the garlic sauce that was so good
it's like so good that it tastes
nasty there's a nastiness to it
if any of them were going to say the n
word and get away with it it would be
the one with the pizza with the garlic
sauce
i'm reaching back for my dominoes you're
so happy during the segment
i've never seen you i'm
reaching back
this is you you're like being the most
you i've ever seen can we please do this
every week
now should we really be responsible once
a month i'll settle
i'm gonna judge it without the garlic
sauce
and i'm gonna give it
a c plus with a garlic sauce and
a plus it changes the whole experience
a plus for me i'm giving
the papa john's
a b because of the garlic sauce
i think the winner is ultimately
dominoes
but i would be really curious next time
to try little caesars
and we should get local ones too oh [ __ ]
little caesars
that was my college pete can you bring
me that garlic sauce back
yeah let's eat them departed and is now
next time we do it we need to have the
garlic sauce from papa john's to try all
of them with so it's an even
even playing field wait annie slow down
you
choked on your way here oh my god i
almost died on my way
you guys this has been quite a day for
my abs you came in like i can't speak
today because i almost i couldn't talk
for the entire car ride over
todd was so happy oh my god did i just
damage my vocal cords okay
we stopped at mcdonald's the
drive-through and i was like i'll just
get chicken sandwich eat it real fast
whatever
todd we are we're driving to the highway
we drive by all these motorcycles
and todd is always of course it does we
just ate it so fast
just did you just dipped i have already
bad food i have to go home
go back into your pool get back into the
ocean water let me rub some tiger balm
on your belly will that help yeah does
that help stomach aches
it works on my balls on your balls
yeah tiger mommy can put on balls i know
you jump in the water it feels even
cooler
oh my god because do not get a hand job
from kaleila holy [ __ ]
unless you're into that that is crazy
holy eucalyptus is very is that why
bobby's always showing me his balls did
you guys have fun when we were doing the
pizza thing
i had fun but not there but i did i did
get into it
i hated it at first i feel like i just
saw you come for the first time did you
guys have fun with
it we'll do it again it's okay so anyway
so we're driving over and todd is 11
years younger than me as you know and he
always is like doing things that
to die before like he'll be like i want
a motorcycle like you're not dying
before me [ __ ] like there's a reason
i'm
so we drive by the motorcycles and i am
about to say you can't die before me
and i've just taken a bite and as i'm
saying it i start choking and todd
starts
he thinks it's to heim like me and i'm
like it's not that bad but i couldn't
talk and
i was i was coughing so much that i
ended up throwing them
into a plastic bag what were you eating
just chicken sandwich from crispy chick
what part sludged
the bread or the chicken it was bo i
mean i really shoved it in fast i was
like
mcdonald's yeah i had to do heimlich on
my mom two years ago so
i have choking nightmares wow is that
hard with her abs to get in there are
you kidding me she was trying to
heimlich herself first
because she's trying she likes to like
muscle her weight she want everything
corner like the coin over table
i don't know what she was doing but she
was like doing some weird launching
things what was she eating
she was doing like a regular dead
monster
you guys do you guys remember when we
tasted the pizza
she's like drunk this is what happens
when you don't drink
she's never done drinking your drugs
look at her and it wasn't sugar
maybe the bread turned into sugar fast
but guys this is really sad i know her
so i know what's about to happen
there's a crash coming really soon like
in
i think we need to put her down for a
nap i think we need to put her down
okay so esther you know how you love the
natural look
you're very against like not against but
you're like no
like i like it when you know
not too much like cosmetic work right
yeah
do you think do you feel that way
about facetune or photoshop yeah i
i don't like when you look at someone's
photos on instagram and you can tell
that they're face
tuned or photoshopped or like too
picture perfect clear
skin or like those rosy cheek filters
i'm like what am i the why am i looking
at this
if you're like you're not a real person
i feel like one of those guys where
they're like i just like a real girl
like i'm like that too
what about the ones that you have that
are face tuned well
sometimes my hair stylist will take my
photos like when you get glam
sometimes the glam artists will take
your picture and then they'll
give it love yeah i have no control over
that
that's the one thing that really [ __ ]
with my self-esteem is when someone
takes a picture and then they alter it
but without telling me
and so i see this image of myself and
i'm like holy [ __ ]
i'm this hot and then i see a reflection
of myself of my actual self like in the
mirror
and then my i'm destroyed and so i think
there's a danger
i don't know which is worse for me like
because i have a cousin
who face tunes out of control
well it's weird when you go unnatural
too this is my take
i think you can allow yourself some face
tuning but you just
don't you can't make yourself look like
you've you
like could never look you have to make
yourself look like
if if i facetune it's gonna be like me
mid pandemic
i'm not gonna give you even pre-pandemic
i'm not gonna like i'm gonna give you
like
me two weeks ago you know yeah not like
you can't do something that's like too
much you also just never want to be in a
position
where you meet someone in person and
they're like
yeah oh like i always want to avoid that
well an hour we don't have a choice
because we're obviously on video every
week
yeah so it's like people do know what
they know about my abs you know i got
them guys
sorry so it's not like we can lie too
much but also like i when i was on
dating sites for
literally 10 seconds it was so [ __ ]
which one were you on i was on raya
my friend karen margolis calls it rich
[ __ ] young [ __ ]
[Laughter]
um follow her she's very funny and then
um
i was on uh i did bumble but bumble was
really
gross i'm like i need a man dude what
sponsor is bumble
okay or sponsor us i i just want i like
men to hit on me so yeah i have to hit
on them it's like no
oh my god i totally disagree why are you
okay
what's your style i go for the guy i
want
he's not gonna come back he doesn't
think he can get you
no i don't get hit on and i say this all
i like have never been because they're
scared of getting arrested
i like to meet in the middle i like to
for someone to come
some of the way and then be in the
middle or meet in the middle both
i'm a medal um but i do i do the work
i'm very assertive
yeah yeah in terms of dating and like
liking someone i tell them
how i think what i feel about them very
same and i don't want to be chased
because
if you're chasing me you're just getting
a high off of a chase and once you catch
me you're going to chase somebody else
you just need a balance a little bit of
bounce like todd wasn't making a move at
first and it was making me
cause i'm like i'm not doing the [ __ ]
first lean and i need you to like
who can take what you need what who
kissed who oh i think i said hocus to i
was like hocus pocus what the [ __ ] is
this
oh yeah hocus pocus too let's do that we
can do it it's coming out
uh no he did because eventually i just
was like
[Laughter]
like there was like a whole hangout
where it didn't happen i was like i'm
gonna [ __ ] kill this kid
and then but then the minute we hooked
up he like had his playstation over i'm
like are you kidding me
i went out of town i was i was on the
road i was on the road over valentine's
day
and we had just been hooking up for like
maybe one week two weeks and we've been
friends before so it wasn't like a brand
new person but
he was like he lived really far away
from the comedy store where he worked at
the time
so he was like can i just stay here he's
like you probably need a house sitter
right
so i have him stay there and i might
even be talking to you about it but i
was like oh my god what if he like
i didn't know him well enough i was like
maybe what if he brings like a girl for
valentine's day back to my apartment or
something
and then it was way worse than bringing
a girl he brought his [ __ ]
playstation
i came back and i was like all right i
guess you live here
you and i are the same did you start
living with dave like pretty early
oh she had to fire her grown nanny
bobby and i are lesbians we shacked up
really yeah i move
fast i have to move fast or else i
have to move on i have to move fast i've
always done that too and it's so funny
with todd i was going to be like
well first of all i was going to break
up with todd so i don't know if i
remember that
it's okay he knows this oh that's right
because he thought he was just going to
be
well i just was like he's [ __ ] 25
like what am i going to do i think he
was 24 at the time
um i was like what am i gonna do this
kid i'm busy i'm ambitious and he was
like don't you want someone to take
help you i was like no i don't like help
and i'm like please do everything for me
but so he is such a [ __ ] liar i'm
like where's the help remember he
promised me all the help
which he does help me but i'm like i
want everything does he still cook and
clean
um he doesn't cook and i remember
well i kept telling him like well he was
my like housewife
and then he i told him like our deal was
that i do nothing and you do everything
and it wasn't contingent on who had a
deal
yes do you want to be he was the one
begging to be my boyfriend i was like
okay well you have to do everything
so then he tricked me and now i'm in
love and i can't get rid of him and now
i'm like i guess i cook
i guess i cook now and the cleaning we
just live in filth until he figures it
out and he's like takes a break from
work but i was like this plan was not
contingent on whether you got work or
not
now he has like this job on netflix he's
doing all this stuff and it's like
sorry dude i didn't say that it mattered
whether you had a job you stuff to do
all this
so we live in squalor well this has been
a joyous day with my slugs in their
bikinis we got so ripped we got to wear
bikini tops we got to eat pizza
yeah it was good it was a good day for
everyone
and i don't want you guys i know you
guys wanted to see bottoms too so i
don't want to like keep
you guys from staying bottom so i'll
show you my bottom oh yeah
okay you can see my ass
do we officially sign off for the first
time with our new names yes
oh we can i don't have anything to show
right i'm just in sweatpants and this is
my top so
she's bottomless if you guys could see
it it's just bushy everywhere i don't
have underwear
yeah i don't i barely wear anywhere yeah
let's sign off with a new name which
we're really excited about
yes guys i think it captures our essence
even better
i think it captures the day we spend
together
trash tuesday you know every
every at every week of yours you'll know
that come tuesday there'll be a little
trash waiting for you
at 9 00 a.m pacific time on youtube a
little garbage
and remember also today is hashtag
uh national donut holding
it's not it is and you guys decide
whether it is or it isn't okay and if
you let her win you're in trouble
so please sound off in the comments like
this video
share with your friends let them know
about trash tuesday
and i guess now we'll have a stripper
episode coming up
check out our only fans check out our
only fans follow us on instagram and
also guys
our little donut holes um
thank you so much give us reviews on
itunes too we'll see you in the garbage
slugs
we'll see you next week
you